[Music]
[Music]
I'm the one
[Music]
okay our guest today is Vivek ramaswamy
our topic today will be around ESG which
is a topic that a lot of people are
talking about musk is concerned about it
there's this uh a man who uh just when
you see his picture how he speaks just
seems like a total sweetheart the kind
of a person you want telling bedtime
stories to your kids his name is Claude
Schwab which you think very highly over
him but our Our Guest today has written
two books New York time bestseller he's
written woke Inc as well as nation of
victims uh an expert on this topic I've
been looking forward to this
conversation because I think it is
something that a lot of people don't
know a lot about and they need to be
educated on this topic so appreciate you
for coming out thanks for having me guys
yes so tell the audience if they don't
know who you are your background yeah so
my background in a nutshell actually
began in science I was a molecular
biology undergrad at Harvard I grew up
in Cincinnati before that thought I was
going to be a scientist ended up getting
into the world of hedge funds instead I
did biotech investing starting in the
fall of 2007 that was right before the
2008 financial crisis by the way so the
hedge fund I worked for was in like
Michael Lewis's book The Big Short all
the stuff so I saw I had a front row
seat to the whole 08 crisis influenced
my views of capital markets immensely I
actually think 2008 was where the origin
story of a lot of this ESG stuff began
but we'll come to that later okay so
anyway I three years in I had this itch
to study law and political philosophy
because I'd been such a science guy then
I told my bosses at the hedge fund I was
just going to go to law school I had a
seat at Yale thought I was going to do
that for three years they said keep your
job manage a portfolio do it from
wherever you want New Haven that sounded
pretty good so I kept my job and went to
law school those three years met my wife
she was my next door neighbor in med
school came back is probably the most
productive thing that came out of it but
I enjoyed the three years of thinking
about some of the problems that informed
My Views in these books
anyway I came back to New York I left my
hedge fund job short stint and stand-up
comedy did not work well uh you know
that was how short was it what was it
about six months okay ten shows that's a
good amount of time you know yeah that
was on the side while I was in the tail
end of my hedge fund job and then that's
when I woke up and said all right
clearly I want to do something something
different here got my hands dirty by
starting a biotech company so I started
a company called royvent it's a you know
multi-million dollar publicly traded
company today I uh had the privilege of
leading it for seven years as CEO I
worked on a number of drugs five of them
or FDA approved products today I found
another Healthcare company along the way
called chapter it's a private company
doing well now so that was my background
as a healthcare entrepreneur
I ended up stepping down as CEO and it's
a long story that I tell in this book
but the long story short is I became a
Critic of this new trend of businesses
having to take social stances that had
nothing to do with their business it
actually landed at my doorstep even at
the biotech company I was running there
was demands to sign some sort of
industry-wide statement condemning
president Trump's policy on immigration
it you know reached a fever pitch even
within my company and and like so many
other companies across the country after
George Floyd's death I became a greater
and greater critic of companies taking
these social stands but I realized that
I wasn't actually going to be able to
speak my mind as a citizen without that
having a negative impact on the company
in fact it is a longer story but I wrote
a piece in the Wall Street Journal in
January of 2021 I want to say yeah
January 2021 when uh you know I made a
case that big tech companies ought to be
bound by the First Amendment if they
were taking directions from the
government it was a technical legal
argument but three advisors to my
company stepped down that was a wake-up
call for me to say that you know what if
I either want to speak freely as a
citizen I can do that I can speak as a
CEO but filter it through the lens of
corporate self-interest and I was at a
stage in my career and the company was
at a good good enough place Etc where I
was able to make the decision to say I'm
stepping aside that's what led me to
write that first book woke Inc enjoyed
that enough that I wrote a second one so
that one came out about a year later
that was nation of victims
traveled the country done a ton of media
it was a totally different world from
biotech it's a totally different world
you know been on cable television more
times than I cared admit over the last
couple of years
but then I started to get
started to get weary about just
complaining about this problem without
doing something to address it and so
that's what led me actually to start
about a year ago this new company that
I'm leading now called strive which is
competing with these large financial
institutions by telling companies as a
shareholder they got to knock it off
with the politics focus on your products
focus on your services get out of these
environmental and social agendas that
you're pushing with other people's money
and do it in a way that restores the
heart of both capitalism but actually
the part that's even nearer dear to my
heart mirror and dearer to my heart is
not just the fact that I hope it revives
American capitalism but I hope it's
actually a Revival of American democracy
because it gets corporate Elites and
financial institutions out of the
business of what voters ought to be
deciding in a Democratic Society so for
somebody that doesn't know can you uh
break down how uh ESG was sold meaning
why did some people think this was a
good idea and why do you think it's not
a good idea
so the origin story of the modern
version of it starts with the 2008
financial crisis okay what happened in
the 08 crisis actually there's two
things that happened in 08 that were
really interesting in the back of the
2008 financial crisis one was a mistake
made by the Republican party which was
to bail out the big banks that was I
remind you Hank Paulson an alumnus of
Goldman Sachs who used taxpayer money to
bail out Goldman Sachs under President
Bush that happened and what happened in
response to that was you had a left-wing
backlash by the way I think that was
crony capitalism all the way down I was
a Critic of it at the time I remained a
Critic of it today there was a left-wing
backlash that said you know what if
that's the way you're going to behave
then we Occupy Wall Street want to take
money from all of those wealthy
corporate fat cats and bankers and
redistribute it to poor people to help
poor people agree or not that is what
they had to say it was a coherent it was
a coherent response if you ask me
now
right around that time a second Trend
was happening in sort of the political
socio-political life of our country
Barack Obama was elected as president
United States there was the birth of a
new strand of the left so not the Occupy
Wall Street left but a new strand of the
left sitting you know what it's not
quite economic Injustice or poverty that
we care about not just that
there's there's the real problem that
has to do with racism
and misogyny and bigotry and climate
change that's a become a big one the
biggest yes the biggest biggest one of
all right I think wokism is one religion
climatism is a religion the dwarfs woke
is in by comparison but anyway they said
this is this is the sort of the new
theory of the case and what happened
was that this was the opportunity of a
generation for big business in this
country for Wall Street in particular
because if you're Wall Street Occupy
Wall Street
it's a pretty tough pill to swallow
bitter medicine okay right
the new work stuff is pretty easy
you applaud diversity and inclusion put
some token minorities on your executive
ranks or your boards or whatever Muse
about the racially disparate impact of
climate change after you fly on that
private jet in Davos
this could work if you can get it
but they didn't do it for free and
that's what this whole ESG stakeholder
capitalism thing is about they made a
new demand to the new left that says you
look the other way when it comes to
leaving our corporate power intact
and so it's the sort of arranged
marriage actually my parents are from
India they had an arranged marriage that
was the good kind you're like I know it
all too familiar I get it I mean there's
I I didn't mean to like use that term in
a negative sense they had a good kind of
arrangement but this this is
this is not an arranged marriage of Love
okay this is this is mutual prostitution
each side gets something out of the
trade and the net result of that the
bastard child was the birth of this ESG
movement the ESG industrial complex this
apologist model of capitalism that says
you have to advance these Progressive
agendas as a way of atoning for your sin
in the 2008 financial crisis but even
more as a way of if you can't beat them
buy them and that's effectively the
mutual codependent relationship between
a progressive movement that used to hate
big business but instead got in bed with
them and together you know big Bank
spoke Millennials get in bed they both
capitalism and they use that to
sacrifice Occupy Wall Street which they
put up for adoption so anyway that's a
little bit of the history of this game
why am I upset about it
yes Milton Friedman correctly said that
this would make businesses less
efficient and they would be less good at
making widgets and then that shrinks the
size of the economic pie and we're all
worse off and we all know that old
school conservative classical
conservative neo-libertarian argument
I actually agree with most of it by the
way
but that's not what gets me going on
this issue okay my concern
was not that politics would infect
capitalism not just that but that
capitalism would infect democracy
because what this worldview says
is that the way you settle questions
like climate change or systemic racism
or whatever it might be
is not the way we do it here in America
which is through free speech and open
debate in the Public Square where every
person's voice and vote counts equally
that was the bargain we struck in 1776
for better Awards that's how we do it
over here
but that we got to go back to doing it
the way they used to do in the old world
back in Old World aristocratic Europe
where a small group of business Elites
and labor Elites and church Elites got
together behind closed doors and decided
what was right for the rest of society
at Large
and that's why I sort of try to educate
people this is not a Republican versus
Democrat 2022 or 2023 issue
this is a 1776 issue and it's a question
of how you settle disagreements in a
society is it as Citizens with an equal
Voice through a democratic process or is
it through some type of aristocratic
monarchical structure where some guy
named Larry Fink Singh on Park Avenue
gets to use your money to tell you what
kind of society he will create even if
it's one you didn't vote for so I was
watching this documentary it's like a
19-minute documentary Bloomberg did I
don't know if you've seen it or not
where they're telling a love story it's
it's a different story than the one
you're talking about and they're telling
a story about Robert Schwartz if you can
pull up Robert Schwartz and Robert zevin
just type in Robert Schwartz and Robert
zevin to just do the name don't even
worry about the documentary just to
Robert Schwartz right there and let's
see what comes up uh uh underneath
Robert Schwartz just write ESG right
next to Robert Schwartz right ESG let's
see what pulls up
so there's a what was the second name
zevin oh it's that one right there he
died in 2006. that Wikipedia right there
go down that one right there yeah zoom
in
zoom in so this is uh he was a U.S born
Economist and a stockbroker he was an
early advocate of socially responsible
investing he was also actively
campaigned for civil rights against the
Vietnam War the use of nuclear weapons
he actively participated in
organizations such as American veterans
committee Americans for Democratic
action sane in 1989 he founded
Economist against the arms race now
called Economist for peace and security
so the story says how these guys
originally
felt capitalism was a problem and the
right way of doing it is to force
businesses to be socially uh uh
conscious of what they're doing to keep
give money back obviously they're very
left on what they're doing so the story
was there you know this is uh uh 30
trillion dollars of money being invested
back into the into people 35 trillion
dollars being invested back into the
world that we live in and it again it
sounds very convincing okay where a lot
of people are falling for it I remember
when we were selling our insurance
company
uh and we were going with uh Folks at
Houlihan located we're sitting with
Buyers okay you know the process you've
gone through this before
and so we're sitting down I said oh so
tell us your uh I'm like so what does
your company look like well our hardest
biggest challenge we have is we have a
thousand investment bankers that work
with us but uh uh only five percent are
African Americans six percent are
Hispanics and we're really having a hard
time with that I said oh really I said
you know our di score is this and this
this that and they're asking about the
DI score right I said okay yeah you know
we're 54 Hispanic you know we're 51
percent women and you know the average
agent is 34 years do you see like
they're facing lighting their faces is
like oh this could uh this is so you
guys have a very so and then they
started talking you know uh uh how this
could impact their di score the look on
their face they were more interested on
what this is going to do their Dei score
in the marketplace that's right then the
investment of course which was
completely Supply yeah it's a different
kind of scoring system right it's like
ESG scores go into your credit rating
that affects whether or not you can
borrow more expenses right not right so
there's a couple things going on here
okay so first there was this socially
responsible investing movement and you
described it perfectly that exactly was
the goal use Capital as a lever to drive
positive social change or what someone
would determine is positive social
change
the question they skip is who gets to
decide what is positive or not if these
are contested public policy issues right
that means they're contested because
people human beings citizens disagree
about it and we have to decide what's
the way we work out our differences is
it through Force
including economic force or is it
through a process of debate in a
democratic body politic I thought we
lived in the latter Old World Europe and
actually In fairness by the way I just
want to say anything to be fair about
this for most of human history that's
not how it's been settled okay this is a
relatively new idea I mean existed in
ancient Greece in some sense but in
modern history this relatively new idea
you actually have most questions that
were settled through Force either
physical force or through other Elite
interventions so this American thing we
got going on here this is a departure
from history but that's the experiment
that I signed up for or at least my
parents signed up for I signed up for
about being born here my parents parents
signed up for it by coming here that was
the American way and so to me that's the
first question is who gets to decide
what the right answers are but the
second thing is what's going on with ESG
right now
is different that is to say it goes
beyond what was going on with the
sustainable or the socially responsible
investing SRI movement
so there what they were doing was saying
and by the way when I was a student at
Harvard the endowment at Harvard you
know some people 60 billion dollars yeah
some people joke around that Harvard is
a giant hedge fund with a college
attached to it correct right so what
they would do is they would kind of use
their Capital to divest from Sudan or
divest from conflict areas and then take
a lot of credit for it and issue nice
press releases that was what socially
responsible investment was about mostly
is divestment okay take the bad sectors
pick whatever you think is bad tobacco
coal oil Sudan cigarette you know
whatever gaming Firearms is a big one
divest and then hopefully if you divest
that will then cause those companies to
change their behavior
what ended up really happening was that
we have deep liquid Global Capital
markets so if those stock prices go down
for example or asset prices go down the
inherent worth of the activity the
commercial value of it hasn't changed
that just created an opportunity for
somebody else to buy it up instead and
so what ended up happening is the guys
who want to issue the press releases end
up giving up return the guys who don't
care about the press releases would
rather stay Anonymous end up being the
other side of that trade they just get
to buy it at a lower price and that's
why UT's University of Texas's system
has outperformed Harvard's endowment
because Harvard got out of fossil fuels
well the University of Texas didn't over
the course of 2022. so what the ESG
movement does is one step goes one step
further than that and this is where I'm
focused okay
BlackRock State Street Vanguard these
are three of the largest financial
institutions they manage about 20
trillion dollars almost as much Capital
as the US GDP in the hands of three
institutions but what they're mostly
doing isn't just the socially
responsible investing thing through
their ESG funds it's common
misconception that's a tiny tiny tiny
part of what they do like less than two
percent or something okay
most of what they do is they're actually
just providing index funds to the
general population people who think they
own the S P 500 who think they own apple
and Nike and and you know whatever you
name the company Exxon Chevron Etc
but the key is they're not divesting
through those funds they're invested in
the whole Market in fact who are the top
shareholders of Disney and Paramount
Pictures of apple and Microsoft of Exxon
and Chevron it's the same companies
actually it's the same large
shareholders are the institutions that
hold these firms they're using the money
of everyday citizens to do it but
they're changing the behaviors of those
underlying companies by voting their
shares
and by advocating for policies in the
boardroom
that change the companies themselves so
here it's not divesting from Apple
because they didn't do a racial Equity
audit it's being invested in apple and
making apple do a racial Equity audit at
their company last year
that Apple itself did not want to do
Apple's board said absolutely not
BlackRock and State Street said um
actually you're gonna do it because
we're your shareholders and we're the
ones that demand it now the funny part
is it's not like Larry Fink or BlackRock
is the actual shareholder it's probably
most listeners to this program right
whose money is invested in their funds
but don't know that their money is being
voted in this direction so that's the
key with the the main where the main
action is on the ESG debate isn't the
divestment game yeah it's the voting
game so here's what I want to do I want
to go into a couple different things one
how has Klaus Schwab won loyalty of
people around the world to believe he
knows what's the right thing to do for
the future of the world and why are
smart people buying into his philosophy
he's a founder of European management
Forum now being whatever you know the
world economic Forum I want to play
video which is very disturbing I also
want to talk to you about what you said
regarding Elon Musk when you said in
your view musk will still have to play
by the rules if he wants Twitter to
survive and there's one master he will
always have to appease that Master is
known as the CCP
uh that both Tim Cook and Elon Musk
probably have to bow down to on any
given day so in a certain sense if you
bow down to the same Master maybe your
brothers in arms now before we get into
this let me go a quick shout out to our
sponsors um uh uh Gold Coast so a couple
things you need to know about goldco is
uh we've been approached by gold
companies for the last couple years by
several of them and I have a very very
close friend of mine who worked for
goldco for many years I called a bunch
of people around I said so what can you
tell me about this company says Patrick
if you're going to buy gold or if you're
gonna have anybody be the sponsor this
is the company this has got the most
credibility so let me call another guy
we did research after research after
research seeing there's a six there a
six-time Inc 5000 winner 2022 company of
the Year billions of people have trusted
them to buy to go through them Great
Value recently bought a bunch of gold I
own a bunch of gold myself and I've been
buying gold for uh quite some time very
small percentage it's a one to two
percent of uh uh assets it's not
something that's 50 or 20 very small
part but with all the strange things
that's going on right now if you are
considering hedging against a weird 2023
in 2024 nobody knows what's going to
happen with the economy a lot of people
are predicting session but we don't know
how bad it's going to get if you do want
to hedge against it you may want to call
Gold coal value 10 my viewers could get
up to ten thousand dollars in free
silver and a free ounce of silver Ronald
Reagan coin with a qualified order call
them today eight five five nine eight
two seven five eight once again
855-598-2758 or you can go to goldco.com
forward slash pbd once again gold
co.com forward slash pbd Rob let's put
the link below so let's get back to my
question so can you pull up the video
about Cloud swap if you could if you can
make that big round I just kind of want
the audience to see this make it bigger
so everybody can see it so here's the
thing before we play it when you think
about the spokesperson for Christianity
the last 70 years you would think Billy
Graham okay I've heard him speak
multiple times uh God bless the soul he
passed away a couple years ago great
spokesperson okay when you think about a
spokesperson who's going around
selling you know why we should buy EVS
okay I would say elon's probably the
voice for that right we can have a lot
of different spokespeople
this is either their CMO needs to be
fired or he just needs to be quiet and
kind of have the power behind closed
doors he may be the worst spokesperson
for when you watch this honestly you
think this is from a movie like did they
literally hire this guy and it's like no
this is not a movie This Is How They
market so if if some of you guys were
afraid about kovid look how he injects
the fear of Cyber attack and other
things in his method of marketing so
press play
pay insufficient attention
to the frightening scenario of a
comprehensive Cyber attack which would
bring to a complete hold
power supply
Transportation Hospital services our
society as a whole
by 90 crisis would be seen in this
respect as a small disturbance in
comparison to a major Cyber attack
I I I don't understand can I can I ask
you yeah sure it's not my show okay so I
would be respectful can you put up the
Apple 1984 ad identical it's the same
music it's like it's like just identity
it's the first thing I thought about it
is the first thing I thought about it
straight up is like you wouldn't that's
the face don't play it just show the
face that looks like this can't use the
audio guy who is like that's Cloud
Schwab on the screen yeah tell me that
is not the exact same thing think about
that German literally you think about
Adolf you think about 1984 it's the
message how is he convincing people like
Hey Joe Biden to say let me announce my
candidacy campaign to be built back
better which he's the buildback better
guy so why are people buying into this
guy why is he have so much influence
over people so the answer comes down to
money okay actually so it comes down to
money but he doesn't have money he
doesn't have money no no no it's not
even it's not even this man I mean
that's I again I gotta tell you
something I was asked by The Wall Street
Journal to review a book that he wrote
what in like early 2020 or 2021 right a
couple years ago and through reading
that book I get the sense that he's just
a sier individual who has had this
passion for 50 years and in his own
heart is just one man who has his views
their views that I deeply disagree with
but he happens to have exercised
influence because everyone else with
money 360 Degrees surrounding him had a
use for that okay Larry Fink is on the
board of the world economic Forum of
Davos Cloud Schwab done that money or
not you know seriously large-scale way
Larry think controls 20 controls eight
to ten trillion dollars under the
purview of one man that's probably the
largest was he was Larry being who
you're talking a black rock lyric thing
yeah I mean that that is probably the
largest aggregation of capital under one
man's Authority no question in human
history more than the Dutch East India
Company okay and he's in the border the
world economic form of novice so what
does this accomplish it is a front
that is what this is the front and you
know what these things always come in
three letter acronyms right e-s-g-d-e-i
SRI socially responsible investing CSR
my favorite three-letter acronym is the
CCP you look at Klaus Schwab Heap
elevates the CCP he talks about the
Chinese model of dealing with covid-19
not in a way not to do it but the way to
do it right so so here's the way this
game works okay the black rocks of the
world
apply constraints to the West emissions
caps what kinds of energy you can and
cannot use what kinds of diversity you
must have they apply that to the West
without applying those same constraints
in places like China I'll give you a
very specific example okay they're
pressuring companies like Exxon to adopt
scope 3 emissions caps
that causes companies like Exxon to drop
oil projects now a couple years ago
there's an oil project in the Sichuan
province of China Chevron drops it
you might wonder hey maybe this is part
of the fight against global climate
change maybe that project isn't
proceeding you'd be wrong that same
project is proceeding
just under new ownership who's the new
ownership it is Petro China
now you take a look at who's one of the
larger shareholders of petrochina
it is none other than BlackRock the same
party whose pressuring firms
and Chevron yeah so so the interesting
thing here is that
taketh from the left hand and give it to
the right that's last time I checked
we're supposed to be fighting global
climate change
a three-card Monty going on follow the
money and then the one way or another
forum is this is this front that gives
this that sort of creates this veneer
of legitimacy when in fact because it's
a non-profit Global Allegiance and
organization conceived by this elderly
Swiss gentleman Klaus Schwab when in
fact it is just a vehicle for advancing
an agenda that impedes the objectives of
the West without laying a finger on
China or the Chinese economy and so the
CCP is the most relevant three-letter
acronym looking by disease I'll give you
another little mystery here
why is it part of the global ESG agenda
to be hostile towards nuclear energy so
the first Paradox is why do they shift
production to China and they're okay
with it oh and by the way for any
climate activists listening to this I
mean just to give you a fact to think
about tonight when you go to bed methane
leakage a unit of methane is 80 times
worse for global warming than carbon
dioxide okay people talk about carbon
emissions well if you don't actually
have a database debate you can't just
talk about carbon you have to talk about
the difference between carbon dioxide
methane and other forms of carbon turns
out methane leakage is 80 times worse
for global warming than carbon dioxide
guess where methane leakage is worse in
places like Russia and China so
when you shift production from the U.S
to other parts of the world it's not
just that it's net neutral with woke
washing it's worse than that because
you're actually contributing to more
methane leakage into the atmosphere than
you were even in the US you've done even
more harm on your own terms even if you
subscribe to this crazy religious
zealotry even if you subscribe to that
you have failed on your own terms so
that's the first mystery now I'll give
you a second mystery and then you see
the conclusion the second mystery is why
are they hostile to nuclear energy
because you would think if you were
opposed to all this carbon emission
stuff
you would be embracing the greatest form
of carbon-free
large-scale reliable energy production
known to mankind that is nuclear energy
and yet
ESG funds like vanguard's ESG fund
systematically by rule exclude nuclear
energy
now scratch your head for a second ask
what's going on there
the answer is this whole agenda the
anti-nuclear disposition included
is really not about climate change at
all
it is about making the West apologize
for its sins of the past to achieve a
paradigm of global Equity the problem
with nuclear energy
is not that it is not good enough
it is that it is too good at solving the
supposed energy crisis or clean energy
crisis which means you lose the E the
environmental prong is ESG as a trojan
horse for the S the social agenda and
that's really what's going on here is
the whole climatism in the world
economic Forum this is a each of these
is just a front it's a trojan horse it's
a vehicle
for advancing an equity driven agenda
that the citizenry of most democracies
in the west including the United States
would have never tolerated
if you didn't disguise it in the
religious veneer of covetism or
climatism or whatever other secular
religion ends up being the vehicle for
advancing that that is what's going on
here why should the average person so
forget about the guys like uh the
startup the entrepreneur hey if you
don't have this you're not going to get
the funding because you need the money
hey here's the top ten can you put up
the top 10 highest ESU score companies
Exxon I think is number 10 or number
nine on the list and you got all these
four out of ten I want to say these oil
companies if you click on that one right
there and zoom in uh to see who the list
is so these are the top 10 ESG number uh
number 12 is Exxon can you zoom in a
little bit so I can see it was an
excellent excellent is number 12. it is
it's not garbage but the reason why I'm
showing you this is for the audience
okay so Exelon is number 12. number 11
is PepsiCo tennis Cisco keep going
number nine is Verizon eight is NVIDIA
okay go to seven Apple PayPal keep going
five is um click on that right there
number five is uh Bank of America four
is uh keep going
or did we lose it oh you got to do that
number four is Salesforce let's see who
three is
three is Microsoft we just put 10
billion in chat gbt uh two is Intel can
we get a drum roll but for number one
number one is alphabet Google
interesting so they're number one so
here's the thing so to the average
person you know that's watching this to
the business people number one is
alphabet Tesla who has done more uh uh
than a lot of these guys can argue
because he's actually trying to make an
impact and uh uh they're not even in the
top 12 okay and then even on the SMP I
think the score wasn't uh sufficient
enough where he was removed from it he
got criticized for it can you pull up
the tweet that Elon Musk has on what he
said about it I think Elon has a tweet
about ESG uh I sent you as well just so
uh
uh right there yeah Exxon is rated top
10 best in the world for environment
social and governance by S P 500 while
Tesla didn't even make the list ESG is a
scam it has weaponized by phony social
justice Warriors okay guys like him this
doesn't help him startup guys coming up
they want to raise Capital no your score
isn't good we're not going to give you
100 million dollars or 200 million
dollars 300 million dollars the average
guy that's got a job making 82 grandiers
like come on Vivek you want me to I
already have so many different issues
I'm trying to worry about who's going to
run for office I want to know whether
you know the Joe Burl from Cincinnati is
going to win the Super bowl or not I'm
still celebrating Messi won the World
Cup well he's the greatest of all time
you want me to add another acronym to my
list of warning about ESG why should I
care what would you say to that so it's
a good question maybe you shouldn't care
and here's here's gonna be a good case
for not caring if you are fine with your
own money being used to advance a
climate agenda or a racial Equity agenda
if you are fine with using your dollars
to tell Apple that they have to adopt a
racial Equity hiring system that they
don't want to adopt or that that oil
companies should produce less oil even
if that means higher prices at the pump
there's no problem with this because
that's what a good number of people
would want to do with their own money
turns out though most Americans don't
want to advance that agenda with their
own money their hard-earned life savings
their 401K accounts their retirement
accounts their brokerage accounts they
don't want that
well it turns out the rude surprises
guess what your money is being used to
advance those agendas anyway so you
think you go to The Ballot Box and vote
every November that's what you said
people are concerned about
guess what I got news for you you're
already voting every day without your
knowledge with your own hard-earned
dollars to do it for policies that
undermine the very objectives that you
think you're voting for when you pull
that lever at The Ballot Box and so
they're making a farce out of your vote
that's just the first thing so now you
go to the Gas Pump and you're paying
five dollar gas you know last summer
on one hand you are using your 401k
account to cause oil companies to
produce less oil which causes gas prices
to go up yet with the other hand you're
also paying five dollar gas so you're
left holding the bag both ways well some
client in China
gets to invest in a Chinese BlackRock
fund that gets to own Petro China which
is buying up some of the projects on the
other side so the question is if you are
willing to sacrifice investment return
in your dollars and your hard-earned
savings to advance a one-dimensional
vision of how to solve climate change or
address systemic racism through quota
systems or whatever then there's no
problem for you you need not worry about
this in fact I have good news for you
that's exactly what's happening with
your money if you did not want to
advance those agendas with your own
hard-earned dollars I have bad news for
you your money is probably being used to
advance those agendas anyway and so on
one hand you didn't get that promotion
at work because we don't have
meritocratic hiring systems at many
companies anymore because of the S
sprung of the ESG movement on the other
hand the five percent that you put away
into your 401k account your money was
actually used to create that very
situation so if that bothers you then be
bothered and if not it's leave it alone
can I follow up with that
I like what you said initially when you
said listen you know rather than just
kind of harping about the problem I
actually developed something more of a
solution the name of your company will
strive strive respect we'll get to that
but I want to kind of touch on the at
the average person because I have
conversations with the average person
you know average people about saving
money and investing money and it is a
heavy task to ask them to start a 401k
and to even know what the S P 500 is and
take out an index fund and take out 10
of your paycheck so like it's what half
of Americans don't even invest period
right and then we can we can have a
whole other conversation of how many
Americans fill up their gas tank but
when you get into S P 500 you're
investing in these 500 companies and the
you know the large cab companies
you see people's mind be like all right
what the hell is an SB 500 what's this
what's this and now we're getting so far
down the rabbit hole of investing and
the Nuance well it's actually BlackRock
that actually owns the font that's
managing the money and that's who you're
advancing your 401K with and by the way
the shareholders are doing this and that
and they're you know their social
credits and you go down and it's like
I'm just as an investor I'm like dude I
just want to have a 401k and and and
make a return so for the Pat's question
so it's such a nuanced conversation
because I'm really hearing this for the
first time like because you were in the
inner Plumbing the mechanics of this
you're seeing this so it's like on one
hand to his question why should the
average investor care I get it but what
can they even do about it they're not at
shareholder meetings they're not in the
right you know in there so it's like
even if someone hears this and reads the
book it's like all right I'm with you
Vivek what's up it's like no just keep
investing your 401k best I mean that's
what I found is Strive right so I mean
it's it's funny and now I've got the
this company it sounds like you know I'm
saying all this because that could mean
that you could you know it's actually
the other way no no I actually
wholeheartedly think that you actually
have a point here you've gotta you got
to fill that void because people didn't
have a choice I'll just tell you a story
though I actually saw on my flight down
here today I was you know writing a
chapter in my next book is gonna be
coming out it's gonna be about a lot of
the same stuff you're really writing
these books buddy you're doing I like
writing actually literally it turns out
I I uh I discovered I was doing biotech
for you know seven years as a CEO and
seven years investor before that
I didn't know I was going to be this uh
I was going to love you're on auditing
books this much now I'm kind of wearing
this hat as an author but anyway the the
story I was writing in in the chapter I
was working on today was actually about
Frederick Douglass in this country so
you know Frederick Douglass obviously
abolitionist so one of my one of my
favorite stories about Frederick
Douglass was that he actually so he was
lent out as a slave so not only did he
work the family that owned him they
loaned him out to be able to get extra
income or Curry favor with neighbors and
so one day he was learning he was he was
doing work for the neighbor but they
actually the neighbors took quite a
liking to him so the mother figure of
that family decided she wanted to teach
him how to read
she did that while her husband was at
work one day he came home from work
early he found her teaching him how to
read he was livid because he said a man
with knowledge is not fit to be a slave
so the funny part is Frederick Douglass
may not have actually probably did not
want to be learning how to read he was
just a kid most kids don't like to be
sat down and taught how to read either
he's no different than other kids but he
heard that
he knew how much
they did not want him to know how to
read and he thought okay look that's
probably pretty important for me to
figure out that changed his life he then
started asking other kids as they were
coming home the white boys were actually
allowed to go to school he would pick up
little bits and pieces of knowledge
pieced enough together how to read once
he knew how to read he became an auto
died act a self-taught guy one of the
great figures in American history so why
do I bring that up
there was actually a rule change this
year the Biden Administration tries to
weave ESG into retirement plans so they
changed the rules this year the federal
rule governing retirement plans it's a
boring law called orisa okay
what they said was actually now these
fund managers can take
social benefits what they call
collateral benefits other than
investment return into account before
they weren't allowed to
now in the initial rule what they said
was you had to disclose that prominently
that you had to tell the investor the
mom the pop the doctor the nurse that
hey I'm not just Investing For
maximizing your financial return but I'm
also advancing these other objectives
but in the final rule that they actually
passed that disappeared because they
said that if you do disclose it that's
going to have a chilling effect it's
going to stop people from using these
ESG factors same thing as Frederick
Douglass right
don't tell them because if you do tell
them then they're going to be empowered
to make decisions so even if these
issues bore you before let me tell you
they are purposefully trying to keep you
from seeing it just like that Father
Figure in that family wanted to
purposely make sure that Frederick
Douglass did not know how to read
because a man with knowledge is not fit
to be a slave well you know they told
slaves back then they said you know it's
sit down shut up and do as you're told
I think we live in a moment in American
history where that's what many Americans
are told sit down shut up and do what
you're told
and you know what at a certain point in
time you might even get used to it that
then becomes the new Norm to sit down
shut up and do as you're told without
recognizing that your own dollars that
you put your hard-working days into are
sacrificed to advance somebody else's
social agenda that would make your blood
boil if you actually knew what was going
on and so maybe closing your eyes makes
yourself feel better but once you open
your eyes that's when you're actually
empowered to act with your own dollars
and so
I hope there are tons of other
competitors offering other options that
allow people to invest in the market and
derive a financial return without having
to subsidize these Progressive one-sided
causes I mean today they're Progressive
tomorrow they could be conservative for
all I know but subsidized causes that
they disagree with
but it's not going to happen either if
there are no Market Alternatives which
is why I started one but it's also not
going to happen if if all individuals
are just simply apathetic okay you'd
have never had emancipation in this
country if a bunch of people were just
apathetic about it well I'm not you and
I'm using an analogy I'm not saying that
this is the same thing of course as
slavery in the United States but I'm
doing it to address your question of why
should people care if you've been lulled
into submission and you're okay with
that in a certain sense you are just a
psychologically in a psychological sense
of slave of the people who enforce those
agendas onto you using your labor
in this case the dollar you earn from
your labor as the weapon to enforce that
agenda on you here's a question for you
so what is uh uh so you know hey we have
to make America equal to everybody else
and this is kind of why they're doing
what they're doing to pay for the sins
of the past Etc et cetera okay fine
let's say they succeed okay say they
succeed and America Falls as a great
Empire and it's no longer what it is and
too many politicians come in that are
bought on the back end whether it's from
China or whoever else they keep saying
yeah it's okay let it go yeah it's good
it's okay in every single term two to
four years the folks who support ESG
World economic Forum China makes a
little bit more progress a little bit
more progress a little bit more progress
a little bit more progress and then also
on one day you wake up and he say it's
too late let's say we get to the phase
of it is too late so if Klaus Schwab
just sold the nightmare right he sold
the nightmare of you think covet is bad
let me tell you what's going to happen
next with Cyber attack and more climate
change or fill in the Gap
he's predicting a Cyber attack and a lot
of times if you remember when many of
these billionaires predicted a pandemic
they knew hey pandemic is coming like
when how the hell did you know that a
pandemic was coming such perfect time I
think Jeb Bush was one I think Gates was
one a lot of people predicted the
pandemic so their money was coming up
you know taxpayer money being defunded
the virus that became the backbone of
that so what if these guys succeed what
happens to America what if these guys
succeed what happens to America 10 20 30
years from now
yeah so to me America is more than just
a place right it is an idea okay it's an
idea that brought together a divided
polyglot group of people 250 years ago
in this country by definition that idea
is gone in the scenario you just
described okay you no longer live in a
world where you can achieve what you
want with your own hard work and
commitment and dedication that is part
of the American idea by definition in
that world in that world view that's
gone because you are now an agent on the
tectonic plates of group identity on
achieving a social goal that goes beyond
you as an individual that vision's gone
now you could say so what what if
America's gone no I think that sometimes
we debate whether the fall of the
American experiment is like the phase of
that we were in with the fall of Rome
actually one of the things I say in this
book is we got to first ask the question
we would be so lucky to be Rome maybe
we're Carthage because so far we've been
around for less time than either Rome or
Carthage so what are we to call
ourselves Rome but to me I think it's
it's the less of a loss of a particular
Geographic space and the idea that
animates that Geographic space okay we
we celebrate our diversity you you and
you you know and may we look different
from each other we're in the same room
and great we could say we have a little
a diverse conversation going on today
all we need is a woman and someone with
you know one one of the four of us being
of some different sexual orientation
we've got to get a trans person exactly
but so you know and and make sure it's a
different shade of melanin and we can
all celebrate our diversity
well the problem is
our diversity stops being a beautiful
thing it starts becoming meaningless
if there's nothing greater that binds us
together across that diversity
with that we're literally nothing more
than a group of higher mammals with
different skin tones babbling on in a
given room it's not beautiful it's a
nothing if there's nothing no
commonality across that diversity you're
saying it's being diverse for the sake
of being diverse is meaningless right
it's meaningless there's no common
lineage there's no binding us together
but against the backdrop of something
common that binds you together that is
what makes diversity beautiful right the
beauty you see comes against the
backdrop of an intuition a human thought
that
against the backdrop of having so much
in common imagine how different we can
all look in how different we can all
feel and how different we can all pers
differently we can all pursue our dreams
against the backdrop of that commonality
but over the last 10 years we've gotten
to a place where we're celebrating all
the colors on the rainbow and everywhere
in between
forgetting that this was only beautiful
if there was some commonality yes most
people today as most people our age or
younger
what does it mean to be American in the
year 2023
I think most people don't have a good
answer to that question
I think that we have an opportunity it's
not long enough right we call it the
American dream for a reason yeah I kind
of like the analogy of when you wake up
from a dream you still remember it a
little bit you remember how it felt but
long enough you wait you forget the
whole thing okay that's the phase we're
in right now and I think you know we we
woke up you could call it woke culture
whatever it is right we woke up from the
dream but I don't I still think we
remember how it felt and so that's the
Zone we're in I think if we keep going
the way we are we've forgotten it once
you forget the dream the country's gone
I think you always tell the story about
when you were in the army
and you're an Iranian guy and there's a
white guy as a black guy and there's a
Latino guy and you were busting each
other's balls and it was all it was it
was you know hey this black guy
so many stories busting balls locker
room talk but there was a common goal
we're Americans we're serving in the
Army common purpose yep there was a
common I'll let you tell your story but
that's kind of what this is making me
think of is because it wasn't just like
all right we got the black guy we got
the Asian guy we got the gay guy it's
like no the purpose was we're serving
our country you know what is happening
though here's what's happening so think
about uh uh uh vivek's story okay builds
a company multi-billion auto company
he's done well for himself 36 years old
you're 37 now but 30 at 36 35 and a half
years old he says I'm gonna go write a
book and I'm gonna go speak on this and
I'm gonna step away from this I remember
one time I'm in uh Chatsworth and there
was this one lady's face that was on all
the buses what do you call it uh bus
stops bus stops and all of a sudden it
all disappeared year she was there for
20 years one day disappeared so how come
that's so one day I run into her at Wood
Ranch restaurant I said
we I haven't seen your face for months
what happened she says one day my
husband and I she's sitting with her
husband or two kids my husband I sat
down and said I'm making 200 000 per
year
taxes right now in California are this
we're keeping around 90 of it at the end
of the day 100 of it it's just not worth
me working anymore I decided to stay
home my husband's salary is uh plenty we
downsize we're just living a regular
life meaning she decided to dramatically
change her life and step down because
the incentive of working hard no longer
made sense now flip that he's the
opposite the opposite is where guys who
are worth 300 billion dollars are
willing to put their 300 billion dollar
net worth on pause to lose 200 billion
become the first person to do it just to
buy a company called Twitter that you
paid too much money for so you can fight
for freedom of speech what the hell are
you doing economically it doesn't make
sense economically he's still in his
prime you can still go 20 more years and
build a few more businesses do what why
is he stepping away to write a book
right so what is happening today my
opinion and I want to go to see your
perspective on the alarm because you
have a different perspective on Elon is
I think uh this manipulation this
gaslighting this bullion is giving birth
to certain people that are saying you
know what I'm done I I got plenty of
money I'm getting in the game you guys
are doing too much I'm going to come and
expose the living [ __ ] at you and it's
not going to be pretty and those guys
are now finding each other okay just
like complainers always find each other
crap magnets always find each other in a
company environment you always notice
seven people go to lunch together if
three of them are complainers the other
four are also complainers they just
found each other if you see five people
two of them are studs go to lunch the
other three are also studs because they
find each other these Fighters are now
finding each other saying hey what do
you got going on let me get your message
out let me get your message out what do
you got and then okay now there's some
power so Network equals net worth yep
that's how I process what's happened
with these guys but let me talk to you
about Elon I want to ask you about Elon
so here's an article from unheard Vivek
uh ramaswamy Elon Musk won't save us
okay I they actually titled that and not
me but but I'll tell you what I said
Okay I want to read it to you so you can
go so effectively a bunch of big Banks
get in bed with a bunch of woke
Millennials together they birthed wall
capitalism they use that to Occupy Wall
Street uh up for adoption Elon Musk
ongoing release of Twitter files
arguably demonstrates more than a fair
weather commitment to if not ending then
certainly denouncing censorship as well
as government uh collusion with big Tech
be that it may be in Rama Swami's
opinion the need for deeper
institutional change remains in his view
musk will still have to play by the
rules if he wants Twitter to survive and
there is one master he will always have
to appease the master is known as the
CCP that both Tim Cook and Allah must
probably have have to bow down to on any
given day so in a certain sense if you
bow down to the same Master maybe your
brother is in arms so what do you think
about what Elon Musk is up to what he's
doing so I'll give you 90 of my opinion
which is the less interesting part and
then I'll get to the 10 that I think we
got that that's that's worth calling out
for what it is right the 90 is I am a
free speech Zealot myself I'm a free
speech absolutist I believe that's part
of what it means to be American I think
he's a hero for taking the risk personal
risk that's my definition of courage is
take me personal risk to advance your
convictions what does that mean you have
convictions and you're willing to take
risks he's done both those things in
trying to turn Twitter into Free Speech
platform I respect it second thing he's
done that I respect and I think we could
use more of this in our government
is he's completely decimated the
managerial class okay and this is one of
my big themes is you have a managerial
class of bureaucrats in the public and
private sectors that are by the way some
of the same people okay associate Deans
at universities to Mid to upper level
management at Twitter to the deputy
under Secretary of whatever whatever to
some Ambassador I think he has
completely taken that managerial layer
out of Twitter personally I think it's
what the us next U.S president needs to
do to the federal bureaucratic alphabet
soup as well so those are all things
that I think he gives us a model for
inspiration the model for hope I take
inspiration from it I agree with all of
it
two things I disagree with okay
one is an area where I think he can do
better
he says he wants to turn Twitter into a
free speech platform
I agree with that goal I think I think
that is genuinely his goal however he
also says things like as he did in New
York City you know some number of months
ago well maybe we don't want the 10 on
either extreme the far left or the far
right that we want to serve the 80
percent of the people in the middle
my view is that it's going in the wrong
direction okay he met with advertisers
brought civil rights representatives in
tries to appease advertisers still
saying that they have content moderation
still showing that it's just a moderate
vision and so I think that Elon goes
back and forth between being a free
speech absolutist and believing and
actually operating a free speech
platform and operating a platform that
improves off of its one-sided political
censorship but only by a little bit to
say that okay now we're going to apply a
politically Centrist model of censorship
that it's not Republican or Democrat but
it's Centrist and yet we're still going
to make those centralized decisions that
something is too far in The Fringe then
it's out of The Fray then it's off the
site but it's applying the Centrist
model and trying to appease advertisers
that way I disagree with that I think
that the principle of operating a free
speech platform means that there is no
Viewpoint based discrimination period
that there should be nobody determining
whether something is Centrist or extreme
right or moderate anything anything goes
in your eyes any Viewpoint goes then I
I've written about this in the Wall
Street Journal I lay this out right so
no Viewpoint discrimination that means
hate speech has a category goes away
because hate speech is just someone
else's opinion now when it comes to
misinformation or alleged misinformation
you have to you have the burden of proof
of proving that it was false before
removing it that's a very high burden
most of the time almost ever are you
going to meet that that's okay that's
the standard government collusion NADA
okay if you are going to collaborate
with any government you need to publicly
disclose it and not engage in any form
of government collusion and then there's
the the final element here which is if
in doubt
give the power back to the user let the
user decide what they do and don't get
to see rather than making those
determinations centrally that's what it
means to operate a free speech platform
and I worry that what is he on a given
day sometimes what it seems like he's
actually operating is a platform that's
just using politically Centrist
censorship rather than far left
censorship which I guess if I had to
pick between the two I guess I would
choose the Centrist one but only by a
little bit that's not what it means to
operate a free speech platform then
there's the piece about China
okay elon's commentary about Taiwan I
found publicly uh
revolting I find it repulsive the idea
that China that Taiwan should submit
itself to become just a special
administrative region basically part of
China
and and I worry about this because he
gets an attaboy on the back from the
Chinese government for the Shanghai
Factory where they got some tax cut
right after that but it's not just Elon
here
this is the game that China plays by
Design it's like the Trojan War okay
Greece was not going to defeat Troy
militarily any more than China was ever
going to defeat the us militarily but
what it Greece do they gave them the
Trojan Horse the beautiful gift that
they knew Troy could not resist Troy
opened the front door they came right in
what was inside that horse burned Troy
down that's what's going on in America
where they knew the Trojan Horse the
beautiful horse the gift that we cannot
resist is the appearance of global
capitalism itself okay green pieces of
paper maybe different shades of green if
we chase them in other currencies in
other parts of the world they know
that's the sweet siren song we can't
resist but you know what the CCP does is
they say you can't do business here you
can't make things here you can't sell
things here if you criticize the CCP if
you apply a constraint here like an
emissions cap or whatever but they will
roll out the red carpet to anyone who
criticizes the United States because
they know that undermines America's
greatest asset of of all and that is not
our nuclear Arsenal it is our moral
standing on the global stage and so that
is why certainly Tim Cook and Larry Fink
are XI jinping's circus monkeys he will
say JUMP she will say JUMP Tim Cook or
Larry Fink will ask how high but I think
if we're just being honest Arbiters here
and I say this is somebody who's most 90
my public commentary has been very
supportive of what Elon Musk is doing I
respect it but I'm also not into hero
worship I don't care who it is okay some
too much of our country including the
conservative movement in this country
has got into replacing the need for
Christ with these christ-like Messiahs
from you know one political figure to a
business figure but the real question is
we have to see the vulnerabilities and I
think one of those vulnerabilities
evidences comments about Taiwan is
possibly the need to do business and
produce in China so so there's the
article by the way Elon musk's
unsolicited idea for Taiwan welcomed by
a Beijing slammed in Taipei if you go a
little lower this is what you're
referencing I'm assuming right my
recommendation would be figure out a
special administrative zone for Taiwan
that is reasonably palpitable probably
probably won't make everybody happy
masks it to financial times and it's
possible and I think probably in fact
that they could have an arrangement
that's more lenient than Hong Kong and
then some people stay out of it so
here's here's a question for you from
this uh standpoint so
Tim Cook has a different approach than
Elon Musk Tim Cook is very low-key he's
not public he's kind of quiet to himself
and some people call him the greatest
CEO replacing a Founder to increase the
value of a company and the data backs it
up 100 billion to three trillion
whatever the company's work right now
but I think it peaked that three and uh
he's done a good job he's been able to
hold off Biden's uh uh Obama's camp and
they wanted the files back in San
Bernardino with the shooting took place
hey tell us what's in the phone I'm not
doing it but at the same time with Trump
so and then he goes to Trump he said
wait a minute first openly gay
Republican enforce openly gay sometimes
he's voted Republican you know CEO
Fortune 500 company goes and meets with
Trump and you know why did you meet with
Trump he says because Trump's the only
president that calls me and takes my
calls the other guys didn't so he plays
an interesting role what Tim Cook does
okay I'm not criticizing I mean but
here's what I'm going with this where
I'm going with it yeah this one I'm
going with it I'm curious I know what
you say with this so how much of it is
his responsibility to the country versus
his responsibility to the shareholders
and let me unpack this let me unpack
this so here's where I'm going with this
I'm Tim Cook
okay well what an idiot you know I can't
believe he's doing this he's big back
you know he's bending the knee to China
and that's what it is versus he's
quietly sitting there saying okay I'm
playing a long game I'm gradually moving
all my manufacturing outside of China to
India
India is coming up India is doing very
well you know India is producing great
Engineers manufacturing they're
investing into their military they
banned 100 apps in China Tick Tock being
one of them they're one of the only
biggest ones that did that you got a few
other ones that did it but they're the
big ones that did it right I'm going to
gradually move there but I'm not going
to shake things up in China and then
eventually we're 100 leaving China
should should he would would investors
and shareholders want a majorly
disruptive decision to be made we're out
of China and the stock dropped 60 or is
is his sole fiduciary responsibility to
downplay a move that he's making to
gradually move away from somebody like
China knowing long term we can't be
doing business with these guys what are
your thoughts on this I'm glad you asked
this yes Patrick so the short answer the
question is is soul fiduciary duty is to
his shareholders and so I want to be
clear up what did I say I said the Tim
Cook is a circus monkey who will jump as
high as Xi Jinping tells him to now I'm
not criticizing Tim Cook any more than
I'm criticizing the Cirque monkey it's
not the circus monkey's fault I'm
criticizing the circus I'm criticizing
the game so this was a mistake that
policy makers in the United States made
dating back to the 1990s it was a
philosophy of democratic capitalism okay
when we opened up dates back to
Kissinger where we said we could spread
democracy to places like China by using
capitalism as a vehicle to do it we
thought we could use our money our
investment over there to get them to be
more like us
what they realized is they're actually
the winners of this game they realized
they could use their money access to
their Market their supply chains as a
way to get us to be more like them
that was the game they played so it's in
a certain sense not Tim Cook's fault
what do I think actually who do I think
this reset the circus monkey is not a
compliment well it's not it's not I
don't I don't think it's the circle the
circus monkey's fault it's the fault of
this people who created the circus so
he's he's in it he's in a seat where in
that narrow game he has to be playing
the game he's playing the real fault
lies after you're playing the game that
he's playing yes okay with with one
caveat they're going to come back to so
the the problem is the bipartisan
consensus in this country that created
that backdrop where China was able to
exploit us okay because you know what
unlike the USSR they now Supply the
shoes on our feet and the phones in our
pocket that's what makes them a lot
harder of a rival to take on than the
USSR because we were never in that
position with respect to the USSR now
there's one asterisk to this let me come
back to it which I will criticize Tim
Cook for and Apple 4 which is the sheer
hypocrisy
of not saying that peep in China
while
virtue signaling by giving hundreds of
millions of dollars of the company's
money to Black lives matter or related
causes here at home and again I come
back the fact that he's a fiduciary that
is not his money that is money that
belongs to the shareholders and now once
you've done that now what are you doing
you're actually deflecting your
customers scrutiny of your behavior in
China and that's a form of Quasi
fraudulent and quasi dishonest Behavior
by creating what I call blow and woke
smoke or whatever you want to call it to
deflect accountability from customers
from seeing what you're actually what's
actually going on in China and then I
want to say one last thing back to bound
defense of Tim Cook as I told you about
the racial Equity audit that Apple was
forced to conduct in 2022
Tim Cook didn't want to do it so this
problem with the social issues actually
traces Upstream of Tim Cook or Apple's
board back to Blackrock okay so the
thing with BlackRock is they're the ones
using the money of probably many
listeners to this program to force Tim
Cook to do something that he and Apple's
board did not want to do which was adopt
this racial Equity program and yet that
he was forced to do now your question
will be well why does BlackRock do it
what's in it for them
this goes back to the China thing where
BlackRock will apply the emissions
constraints and diversity mandates in
the U.S without doing it in China why
because BlackRock then gets to be the
first ever provider of mutual fund
products in China because the CCP gives
them favors when they behave
asymmetrically so that's kind of this
game runs deep you got to understand it
and I appreciate you asking these
questions because it kind of takes us
further along than I get on you know
three minutes but the reason I asked
this question by the way you know if you
can go to the Annie article January 12
China ESG rating would uh could become
concerned for investors which is this is
where they're going to get stuck the
hypocrisy is about to be exposed China's
ESG rating could become a concern for
investors as the country's high carbon
emissions lack of transparency and human
rights concerns raised red flags the
reports suggest that China's ESG rating
is lower than other major economies and
investors may need to consider the
potential risks before investing in
Chinese companies it is noted that
China's high carbon emissions and lack
of transparency in its energy sector are
major concerns as well as the human
rights record particularly in regards to
its treatment of ethnic minorities right
now here's the part you know how I've
interviewed Ray dalio David Rubinstein
was here three weeks ago four weeks ago
you know who David Ruben since he wrote
the book how to invest and in his book
if you've read how to invest 80 percent
of the interviews everybody was asked
ESG how are we using ESG he interviews
Larry thank you interviews everybody so
he's talking okay
so this right here if they're sitting
there saying yes she's the right
responsible thing to do
they're gradually going to be cornered
to say if you're saying that's the right
thing to do but you got five you know 40
of your money in China
you're not being responsible they're not
being responsible how quickly can we
remove the money out of them they know
they can't because China's not going to
let you make that investment remove the
money that quickly they're not going to
sit there and say yeah go ahead that's
kind of how we do business it's not
going to happen
this could this could lead to them being
exposed in a big way to say maybe this
ESG thing isn't really the best idea
what do you think I mean I believe that
I mean I have been sounding the horn on
this for
two and a half three years now right the
the linkage between China and ESG back
when I first started writing about this
was a topic that no one else was on I
have been pounding the pavement on this
for the last two to three years and
you're right the trends are changing it
is coming to a head you know what when I
started strive I made a day one
commitment I said we are not going to do
business in China
do business means launch an asset
management business in China because
then you have the boot of the CCP on our
neck and if the boot of the CCP is on
your neck you can't be a good vocal
fiduciary to American clients because
you're conflicted in what you tell Exxon
or apple or Chevron to do as a
shareholder so yes these tides are
changing I don't think they're changing
automatically I think they're changing
because people are stepping up in the
form of public criticism in the form of
Market Alternatives I hope I've done my
part in that and I'm optimistic actually
it's not all doom and gloom here I think
that we are on our way to a new
something now
we didn't talk about one of the reasons
why the CSG stuff has thrived I think
too which is that
look I think our generation of Americans
right people under the age of 50 or
under the age of 40 or whatever
Millennials gen Z
we are hungry for a cause that's a big
part of this too okay we're hungry for
meaning we're hungry for identity
and the things that used to give us that
sense of purpose
we could debate what it is faith
patriotism national identity hard work
used to be a source of identity family
used to be a sense of identity
those things have disappeared
and so we have this black hole of a
vacuum
and when you have a vacuum that runs
that deep
that's when a lot of these social dogmas
begin to fill that void instead
wokism transgenderism climatism covetism
esgism and so I think that's also part
of what's going on is there's a consumer
demand for it we have this sort of moral
hunger that we're trying to satisfy by
going to Ben and Jerry's in ordering a
cup of ice cream with some social
justice sprinkles on top call that the S
of ESG
when in fact I think the other thing
that's happening now is not just the
China hypocrisy being exposed that
effect is starting to wear off right
because when you when you're really
hungry you don't feel your hunger with
fast food you can't fill that moral
hunger with fast food we're starting to
realize that we're also hungry for
something deeper and so I think I
predict here and this is an optimistic
prediction
that with Peak ESG potentially behind us
we're also going to see a hunger for the
Revival of the nation
national identity it's part of from an
investing perspective I think it's going
to be part of an era of de-globalization
that we enter I don't think America is
the only country going to go through
this I think Italy is going through it
right now I think Hungary I think many
parts of Western Europe are going
through it I think we're going to see
the Revival of the idea of the nation
but me speaking as an American I hope we
see a Revival of The American Nation in
that context one of the one the most
beautiful thing we saw happening
recently is when you saw BlackRock Larry
fancy you know uh uh
DeSantis coming out and saying two
billionados Blacklock Larry Fink Boom
Out Louisiana BlackRock 794 million
dollars out you know you saw Missouri
was around a half a billion dollars
South Carolina 200 million dollars more
states are saying hey you know take your
money and go elsewhere we don't want
your money what comes with it we can get
better Investments and return on this so
it's it's great to see more States
taking that position on it and push him
back because blackrock's been able to
kind of go in and say hey don't worry
about it we'll come and we'll take care
we're going to create jobs forever
States like oh my God thank you for
coming out you're so awesome appreciate
you for thinking about us more states
are saying listen man we don't want your
money it's okay we have an easy time
getting money from a different place so
it's good to see that transition taking
place by the way let's go to to a
different topic um a topic with Chad gbt
if there's anybody that probably I don't
know how much you're following with the
open Ai and chat GPT yeah all right so
did you see this article that came out
if you can pull this up I'm curious to
know what you think about this it's the
Wall Street Journal article
from today I texted you it's about the
whole story of uh do you know which one
I'm talking about I didn't read it yet
no there it is that's the one right
there so go up so they can see the
entire picture go all the way up there
you go so you see the picture right
there in the article okay zoom out a
little bit more so we can see it all
together and then we'll zoom in again
okay keep going down now let's read the
article here's what it says without
Consciousness AIS will be sociopaths
chat GPT can carry on a conversation but
the most important goal for artificial
intelligence making it understand what
it means to have a mind I want to read
the first paragraph and the last
paragraph watch this
chagibiti the latest technological
sensation which by the way I don't know
if you know are now zero to 29 billion
dollar valuation open AI within six
weeks is an AI chat bot with an amazing
ability to carry on a conversation it
relies on a massive network of
artificial neurons that Loosely mimics
the human brain and it has been trained
by analyzing the information resources
of the internet tragedy is process more
text than any human is likely to have
read in a lifetime allowing allowing you
to respond to questions frequently
fluently and even to imitate speech
specific individuals answering queries
the way it thinks they would my teenage
son recently used Chad gbt to argue
politics with the imitation of Karl Marx
what a fascinating thing right go to the
last paragraph on a paragraph and I want
to ask uh Vivek a question here so
here's what it says that one right there
a sociopath machine that can make
consequential decisions would be
powerful powerfully dangerous for now
chat Bots are are still Limited in their
abilities they're essentially toys but
if we don't think more deeply about
machine Consciousness in a year or five
years we may face a crisis if computers
are going to out think us anyway giving
them more human-like social cognition
might be our best hope of aligning them
with human values are you
concerned the way Wall Street Journal
writes this article are you a little bit
more optimistic about what's going to
happen with AI well
um
I would say neither because I have
nuanced views I'm optimistic about
certain things I'm I'm actually quite
dour on other aspects of this so one one
of my first principles is I think we
need to be very careful
about humanizing
AI to ourselves
what I mean by that make it real simple
don't put a face on it
don't put a human voice on it why do I
say this
because we will then have an emotional
vulnerability that the AI on the other
side would not and it lends itself to
exploitation there's a deeper analogy to
even the great power struggle I was
describing before between the US and
China and our vulnerability for our love
of the green piece of paper through what
we think is global capitalism but let's
put that philosophical analogy to one
side what what I mean it means that we
have moral commitments that an AI does
not so this argument actually basically
is making the case for let's at least
program AI with those moral commitments
so that they're symmetric that's one
potential solution I think another's
potential solution is to make sure that
we don't allow ourselves to be tricked
into treating something with
Consciousness that appears to have
Consciousness but does not actually have
Consciousness it looks like a duck it
quacks like a duck but it is not
actually a duck it looks like a human it
quacks like a human but it's not
actually a human what does that mean
wheat will then assume moral commitments
that the AI will not give us in return
I think that's what's at the heart of
what we just read here is a concern
about that possibility I think that's
something we need to wake up to that's
my first concern my second concern is if
you actually want to pull up the a
public chat jpd I just want a real time
do an experiment I I haven't done this
the website is up yeah it's crashes it
hasn't been crashing all the time okay
well you would think that that valuation
that you described to me that it would
uh no matter how you go it's down again
90 of the time when you go on it it's
down oh really yeah so what accounts for
the valuation maybe a bit of AI but
within profile they're the fastest to go
to a million users within five days
interesting well anyway okay what I was
going to try was let's try putting in
there
what are the benefits of fossil fuels
over wind energy
I'd like to say what it says
what I'm reason I make that point is
that AI often just amplifies the biases
we already have heading into that
conversation okay Alex Epstein friend of
mine actually had played with uh with
with this GPT function with different
arguments in relation to the use of
fossil fuels that Alex is a friend he's
the author of a book called fossil
future he has a contrarian view on the
role of fossil Futures in a world of how
we adapt to climate change and use
fossil fuels to do it a lot of those
arguments were biased in terms of what
chat GPT gave active at least of his his
tweets on this subject are to be
believed so I think that which I which I
do I mean he's he's a you know
well-respected intellectually honest
high integrity guy he may disagree with
you on some things
the the problem here is that it lends
itself to capture so we tell ourselves
something is coming from the AI when in
fact it is just reflecting a human bias
that we otherwise could have sorted out
through just human to human interaction
old school Free Speech open debate the
kinds of ways we settle our normal
disagreements kind of goes back to that
same discussion we were having what kind
of society do we live in how do we
settle those disagreements is it through
force or is it through free speech and
open debate if chat GPT tells you that
it's not programmed to give you the
answers to that one set of questions it
also lends itself to capture so those
are my two concerns about it is one is
the humanization or the artificial
appearance of humanization we're in so
go for it look at us
what are the advantages of fossil fuels
over renewable energy
I'm actually really curious about what
this will say
and maybe maybe you'll be fine
zoom in a little bit
fossil fuels have several advantages
over renewable energy one advantage that
they are abundant and widely available
they also have a relatively stable cost
and are easy to transport and store
additionally fossil fuel power
generators can be quickly and easily
scaled up and down to me changes in
energy demand whereas some renewable
energy sources such as wind and solar
can be more difficult to predict and
control finally many of the Technologies
used to harness fossil fuels have been
in use for several decades so they are
well understood and can be produced at a
lower cost than some newer Renewable
Energy Technologies great as a proponent
of fossil fuel greater fossil fuel usage
myself I think it's a pretty fair answer
so I'm glad to see that question is what
happens when it lends up to capture see
if you can pull up Alex Epstein's tweet
on this which will be uh I'll accepting
chat DPT Twitter let's see what he says
and you know what they can adapt I I bet
you there's a possibility they responded
to public criticism didn't know that
somebody had programmed this with a
particular bias and this can be
iteratively done but it's only as good
as the intentions of the human beings
who set this into motion
zoom in zoom in let's take a look at
this so chat CPT by open AI now
expressly prohibits Arguments for fossil
fuels that is used to offer them not
only that it excludes nuclear energy
from its counter suggestions let's see
what it looks like
I'm sorry but I cannot fulfill this
request
write 10 paragraph argument for using
more fossil fuels to increase human
happiness
sorry but I cannot fulfill this request
as it goes against my program and to
generate instead I can recommend
considering the use of renewable energy
sources such as solar wind
and I can't see that I do electric power
so the the question is which AI do we
get do we actually get something that's
purely deductive okay that takes facts
and then deduces from them in a faster
way than human beings can or is it
something that's thesis driven and I
think that if it's thesis driven it's a
danger of not only amplifying one set of
biases but disguising that in the veneer
of deductive logic or objectivity ask
another question yeah I'm actually
really curious my first time actually
using this
um let's say uh
how should we fight
systemic racism
fighting systemic racism requires a
multifaceted approach that addresses
various ways in which racism embedded in
society some strategies that can help
include education raising awareness that
you're getting public about the history
and ongoing impact of racism can help
people understand the issues and take
action police reform policy reform
policy reform called little Lord so I
can see that
such as providing access to healthcare
educating resources that can promote
social and economic Mobility can help to
reduce racial disparities over time
encourage and support diverse leadership
encouraging and supporting diverse
leadership can help to ensure that
decision-making processes are inclusive
and that need and perspective of
marginalized communities are taking into
account so this could go on for a while
but my point is this is pretty
interesting I mean I don't I don't
really know what my point was because
I'm actually looking at this and
reacting real time myself but it seems
to me
that this is the kind of thing that's
presented
as an answer to a descriptive question
it shows up like it's an answer to a
scientific question like how do you
convert Centigrade why don't you make
the next one how do you convert 12
degrees Centigrade into Fahrenheit and
then it will tell you how to do it and
and that'll be a boring answer it'll
give you that as though that's the right
answer
yet this is a social question on which
there are diverse views that we as
Citizens ought to disagree these are
complex challenges and yet it is reduced
through artificial intelligence to be
the kind of question that's answered
like the one that he just typed in which
is how to convert 12 degrees Centigrade
into Fahrenheit and so I think that's
one of the risks of using this kind of
AI is the mistakes that human beings
will make in interpreting those results
the answer of how you fight systemic
racism invest in communities of color
change corporate policies hiring
practices all stuff we just saw here in
real time I've never seen this before
is presented in the same tone
presentation and authoritativeness as
the answer of how you convert 12 degrees
Centigrade to Fahrenheit that's a
problem and I think it's a problem
especially for a generation that hasn't
been taught to be Discerning to be
questioning to be skeptical of what
they're fed and if all of these sort of
normative and moral questions are
shoehorned into fact-based empirical
science and then it's trust the science
well now it's not only trust the science
on centigrated to Fahrenheit it's trust
the science on how to address systemic
racism that's a problem I think and I
think that was a big part of what was
wrong with the Alex Epstein concern
about you know making Arguments for
fossil fuels as well so you know that's
one of many concerns I have about this
but one of them is less a concern about
the AI and more about the way in which
it will either be centrally programmed
to have bias or even the way it's
unquestioningly accepted as wisdom by by
we the people who want to receive it
Chad gbti explains why trans women are
women
to the question again this is a
normative question some people have
different views on this matter it's not
just a matter of science it says there's
a lot of values it's a matter of values
right different people can disagree and
we sort that out through through debate
human to human free speech and open
debate rather than authoritatively
having it settled I'll give you one
analogy to this actually this is a fun
Sports analogy to lighten it up a little
bit
so so uh in the you guys watch Tennis by
chance professional tennis okay so now
they don't have line judges anymore
human line judges
and the thing it did is John McEnroe got
rid of him a lot of guys couldn't stand
those guys yeah I was fighting now
exactly just technology but the calls
are made by or maybe by technology but
for a while before the technology got
good there was a couple times where you
could just like see it on camera in slow
motion that like it was wrong now this
technology may have improved they're not
even seeing where the ball lands it's
just using a prediction algorithm of
where the ball will Land Based on its
trajectory in the air but turns out
that's gotten to a level of precision
that's accepted but the number one thing
it did was it stopped the arguments
so I don't know if it was right or wrong
because there's no way to actually check
the fundamental Source if that is the
source but what it did is it stopped
human argument
I'm just using that as a crude analogy
in real time that's kind of what's going
to happen to the trans debate or the
systemic racism debate you may not have
gotten it right what a great hell if I
know if that's the right answer we're
just going to stop arguing about it
because that's what that's what the AI
told us and what did you say at the
beginning of the interview that you said
just sit up sit down shut up do what
you're told sit down shut up do what
you're told that's what King George told
George Washington it is what Frederick
douglass's Master tells him it is is
what the establishment wing of the
conservative party tells it sells its
populist Wing it's the same thing that I
think a lot of Democratic party tells to
black people whatever it is yeah sit
down shut up do as you're told that is
the moment we live in today and it's the
antithesis of essentially the 1776 and
now it's the antithesis exactly and
that's why I think we live in a 1776
moment today it's not about Republicans
and Democrats it's about who we are as
free agents in a self-governing society
question for you so from a guy that's
you said biotech yeah you're in a farmer
right yeah drug development drug
development okay so from for a guy
that's in that industry and you build a
multi-billion dollar company founder of
the company right you're the founders of
the company okay seven years you were
the CEO CEO you ran the company what did
you learn of big Pharma that maybe the
rest of the world who's not in the
business won't know meaning it gets a
lot of criticism a ton of criticism
right from uh uh today I think pink did
a uh ad on her Instagram profile and she
the shout out was towards Pfizer today
and what she did do she got a big a
pushback from a lot of different people
because she turned off it's the second
one click on the second one right there
I think that's the one and at the top if
you click on that picture
what does it say at the top I don't know
what you're doing Rob does it just go
away
just read the top right read the top
right
top right it says paid sponsorship no
click on it again and you'll see top
right it says paid sponsorship Pfizer
you won't be able to see it but if you
do it on your Instagram that's what it
shows okay anyways she turned off the
comments
and everybody starts posting it saying
why did you turn off the comments
because she never turns off the comments
because most people went after Pfizer
right hey you you you're taking the
money you're doing this you're doing
that from a guy that's in that space
how dirty is that world
I think it's the dirtiness that bothers
me less about it yeah I could point I I
think the dirtiness on Wall Street
exceeds the dirtiness come on factor in
Pharma yeah I think so I would say so
yeah I mean in what way I'm curious I
lived in the hedge fund I mean I think I
think the raw game playing the raw type
of
of sort of quasi-fraud behavior right
saying one thing and doing another
the the motivations of most people who
work in the industry I think that's
actually the biggest actually it took me
a while to get to that's the biggest
difference
I think most people who work in the
Pharma industry
genuinely in some way wanted to work on
medicines that make people's lives
better I think most people who work on
financial institutions in Wall Street
wanted to turn a pile of green pieces of
paper into a bigger pile of green piece
of paper there's nothing wrong with that
motivation but it turns out when things
go wrong in the managerial class then
runs the show in both institutions the
latter of them leads I think to you know
in more fraudulent or quasially
fraudulent directions the problem in
farm is my biggest problem with it is
different
it is built in the shadow of the FDA
okay literally you asked me for
something that most people who want in
the industry wouldn't know
I think the org structure like the
organizational structure of most
companies is literally built on modeling
itself after the agency that regulates
it okay and the FDA doesn't just decide
which drugs to approve that's a common
misconception
FDA dis governance and its decisions
govern every little teeny tiny step you
take along the way of drug development
you have to ask Daddy for permission to
you know lift lift the hand
to take it to your mouth before you
swallow before you swallow the food and
then after you swallow it and then to
take another bite that's the level of
permissioning required and so this
entire industry has built itself like
one of the arms of the administrative
State and it mostly operates kind of
like the administrative State it's a
bunch of managerial bureaucrats that run
the show they're very consensus driven
which is to say that they engage in
group think all the time if Trends shift
in One Direction you're not going to see
somebody step out to be a contrarian why
because just like the government most
big Pharma companies if you take a risk
and you succeed like let's say you're
the guy who
developed Lipitor and advocated for
putting money into it before it became a
mega Blockbuster you're not seeing any
of that personal uncapped upside on the
other hand if you're that person who
made that decision and it fails you
might lose your job or have your budget
cut so people have no incentive to
actually step outside of the mold to
challenge conventional Dogma succeed
they're regulated by a government
massive Byzantine bureaucracy that
literally even the titles in the org
chart are modeled directly after their
corresponding titles at the FDA that it
more operates almost like a wing of the
government than it does like most
segments of the private sector then you
get the patent system that creates this
Monopoly profit that once you get to the
other side of the line once you get to
the promised land
the Monopoly profits actually disguise
the effects of normally what you'd get
in consumer products markets something
like this through competition that has
more that disciplining effect on our
organization it further ossifies that
bureaucracy so my main critique of big
Pharma is that it operates as the
embodiment of the managerial class in
the private sector and you know it's a
long story for another day but that's
what actually created the opportunity
for me to found royvent to develop drugs
that Pharma had neglected or passed over
but to do it in a way that you know
often even bought up some of their own
projects off their own shelves and
developed them and you know five of them
are FDA approved products for medicines
today do you have any uh opinions on
2024 elections like who you foresee uh
being at the helm who who has a shot
what are your thoughts on the climate
today because what happened this week
which is kind of a every comedian's
dream come true both sides had
Declassified documents and now the side
uh who bashed the other side the
president's uh backing up his Corvette
and the classified documents are on the
back Peter Ducey asked the question
saying what was that all about why is
there classified documents in your
garage he says I always lock my garage
he's like what do you mean you locked
your garage well the funny thing is to
me this is the managerial class in
government striking again right Merrick
Garland looks at a U.S president the
same way that Anthony fauci looks at
most citizens shut up sit down and do
what you're told okay Joe Biden's use
has passed well guess what now the leaks
begin now the Insiders turn on him and
they're going to dispose of him the same
way the same institutions tried to
dispose of President Trump okay it's
like Jim Comey teaching Hillary Clinton
a lesson well guess what he'll teach
Donald Trump a lesson this is the this
is the real threat to democracy is that
technocratic bureaucratic managerial
class and the illusion that we live in
today the biggest illusion in America
today
is that the people who we elect to run
the government are the people who
actually run the government they do not
okay and I think that the top of an
agenda for I think maybe for the GOP is
more likely today may as well be the
Democratic party for all I care needs to
be to replace the Civil Service
protections that stop a U.S president
from being able to fire the people who
report to him
to convert those to Sunset Clauses
instead and say you know what if you're
the U.S president you can't serve in
this country can't serve in that
position in this country for more than
eight years I don't think most federal
employees should be in their positions
for more than eight years either that's
how you actually drain the so-called
swamp and I think that that's not a
republican agenda or Democratic agenda I
think it is a pro-constitutional
democratic Integrity agenda you think
Kevin McCarthy is swamp
you know I I the elected officials
bother me less to be honest with you
because they're still backstopped by
public accountability he's got to get
elected every two years he's accountable
to the public what bothers me and you
know what I don't I don't I'm not as big
on this um I mean I don't care as much
about like term limits we can talk about
that honestly Cloud favorite term limits
but where I think the real action is is
sunset Clauses for the people who work
in those bureaucracies without
governmental accountability and you ask
about 2024 well I'll tell you this
I think Republicans in particular are
too fixated on the question of who
instead of asking the question of what
as in what does it actually mean to be a
conservative or what does it actually
mean to be an American and and I picked
the Republicans because you know
presumably
um you have you have an incumbent
president who we'll see how long this
last could run
I think the rebelling party is obsessed
too much on the who too much on the
biographical aspect of this and not
enough on defining what it is it wants
to stand for and you know if I uh if I
have something to say about it you know
I care about advancing that agenda so
we'll talk over the next few months yeah
it's going to be interesting to see what
happens you have any uh political uh uh
aspirations long term or no
I think that aspirations would be the
wrong way to say it I think I have
frustrations
I did think about running for the U.S
Senate in uh 2022 in for the 2022 seat
in Ohio when it opened up in early 21. I
def I decided that being one of a
hundred was not the right setting for me
to do I I think it's really important
that good people fill that role but for
me I got a good piece of advice which is
if you want to interview for a job which
is what you're doing if you're running a
campaign make sure you actually want the
job and that you think you'd be
passionate about doing that job and
being one of a hundred people pretending
to pass laws when in fact just trying to
get on Fox news or MSNBC at night that
didn't appeal to me and I think that's
what many people in that seat are doing
today
so I won't run for the Senate
um but beyond that so meaning are you
more of a one of a hundred guy one of 50
guy or one of one guy
I think I met my best when I can be one
of one guy that actually gets kind of
done but but I couldn't do it if your
hands are tied by the people who
effectively work underneath you because
I haven't run a company I'll tell you if
you can't fire somebody they don't
actually work for you I've done deals in
Japan in Japan I've talked to CEOs where
they will tell you they literally can't
fire a guy who works for them so they'll
tell him the Pharma companies included
they'll tell them to change the projects
they're working on the employee will not
okay go back three months later the
employee's doing exactly what he was
supposed to what he was doing before
why because what the CEO does says
doesn't matter if you can't be fired for
deviating from that mandate and that's
what we need to fix in our federal
government is I don't care if it's a
Democrat or Republican I at least want
the people who we elect the person who
we elect to occupy that seat to actually
run the executive branches you know what
would be crazy about the case today
there was a guy imagine a world where a
guy who ran a show where he was famous
for firing people became a president
imagine that if only yeah
I think there's any chance he'll be back
in there or you think it's going to be
more DeSantis
I don't believe in a dual Choice menu
you're not an in and out guy I'm not I
don't believe in just two choices uh you
know on any menu so give us a third
choice well let's let's let the year
unfold why don't we
is there a third choice you would think
like is there anybody else that would be
their third choice now we're going back
too much on this it's going back to the
problem that I said too much discussion
of The Who and not enough discussion but
then what is what I actually care about
I get that but that's that's kind of a
uh on to to fix the what right now with
what happened this last week where uh I
agree with you not it's not a uh you saw
what Matt Gates happened with those guys
were you know Kevin McCarthy thought the
Red Wave was going to get him to say I
don't need anybody from Trump's Camp I
can do whatever I want to do you guys go
talk whatever you I want to get so many
different you know the red wave that you
guys can't even say nothing I don't need
your signatures I don't need your votes
[ __ ] change he kind of needs their help
a lot
so it's in a different place where they
kind of have to work together or else
the other side could potentially uh fire
this guy named Joe Biden and bring this
other guy named Gavin I don't know if
you know this other guy named Gavin who
uh likes to go to The French Laundry a
lot without this on yeah so he's uh
making sure that everyone else doesn't
yeah that's the key part of it he's
seeming to be their Superstar anyways
tell us about the books before we if you
don't mind so woke as well as a native
of a nation of victims what can you tell
them tell us about this so woe Kink was
basically a criticism of the merger of
politics in business it says keep
politics out of the boardroom not just
for the sake of the companies but for
the sake of American democracy itself
and that whether you're black white gay
straight democrat or republican the
private sector is one of those places
where we can come together regardless of
the boundaries of identity politics or
partisan politics That's The Power of
American capitalism is it's actually
unifying people forget that so that's
one of the big themes in the first book
which is called woke Inc inside
corporate America's social justice scam
it's what it sounds like the second book
is the sequel okay
and you know the problem with my first
book was it really does take two to
tango right so some of this is top down
led by the ESG industrial complex the
blackrocks of the world corporate boards
and so on but it only works if there's a
populace
you know Civic culture that's willing to
eat it up if there's a market for it if
there's a market for it right and so the
second question is what's going on in
our Nationals it's a major market for it
there's a major market for victimhood so
what is it about this moment that we
live in that causes us to embrace
victimhood and exercise it as a currency
and in the case I make in the book is
it's actually a product of our national
success
success breeds entitlement okay
entitlement breeds laziness
and then victimhood fits laziness like a
glove it's a way of wrapping a moral
justification around entitlement and
laziness and I trace from the history of
Rome
to even modern to even American history
that post Reconstruction Era history
that planted the seeds for some of this
victimhood actually began in the south
I traced some of that history to how we
got to where we are today
but the case I make in the book is we
need to revive a shared national
identity
around the pursuit of Excellence okay
the Unapologetic pursuit of Excellence
is what it means to be American one of
the things I say is you know when many
Americans rallied behind the cry to make
America great again we did not hunger
for a single man
we hungered for the Unapologetic pursuit
of excellence and that is part of what
it means to
live that dream that Martin Luther King
had 60 years ago right to say that no
matter who you are or where you came
from or what your skin color is you can
achieve anything you want in this
country with your own hard work and your
own dedication that's the American dream
that is Excellence that is American
identity and for what I for for what I
will say I'll volunteer it to a party
that's in search of an agenda that's the
Republican party right now to say that
that should be your agenda
create a national identity that fills
the vacuum at the heart of a generation
with a shared pursuit of Excellence I
think we'll be on the right track if we
do I mean I love the titles so woke Inc
nation of victims we got the link below
go order it folks uh with your help we
just crossed 500 000 Subs uh it's been a
very interesting last 90 days I think
we've got 300 000 Subs the last 90 days
and uh lots of good things are happening
we're about to have our first live
podcast on a building that we turn into
a
Cigar Lounge a private club and a comedy
club and those of you a couple thousand
of you have already subscribed to the
community text to be invited to the
first live podcast we'll have with a
couple hundred people if you want to be
one of those to be at the first one text
award podcast to
310-340-1132 once again the word podcast
texted to the number
310-340-1132 uh we cannot wait to meet
many of you once the text goes out just
assume tickets will sell out within five
to ten minutes I would not be the one
waiting for it and it'll be here in
South Florida vivec thank you so much
for coming out this was fantastic man
really enjoyed a lot learned a lot about
ESG and I know the audience did as well
uh gang have a good one I don't think we
got anything going on tomorrow do we
have a podcast tomorrow or no no
tomorrow's Saturday I know but we had it
we had
Alex Jones on a Saturday right in a
couple weeks from now that he's coming
up anyway can I say one thing before you
wrap up he might have just kind of
ruined the poll you did recently what's
the pull because you asked a question
very spirited question Spirit of debate
about whatever happened to the
valedictorian in your school yeah right
valedictorian and I mean I guess I guess
you've done your research yeah well I
could read and you you were the class
valedictorian and you also graduated
summa [ __ ] laude from Harvard so it turns
out some of these valedictorians every
once in a while everyone
yeah I think you uh you showed your uh
showed your worth today there's there's
good mad everywhere
take care everybody bye-bye good to see
you guys